droht krieg an europas grenzen die
situation an der russisch-ukrainischen
grenze spitzt sich immer weiter zu
mittlerweile sollen sich rund 100
tausend russische soldaten im
grenzgebiet aufhalten der grund ist
unklar plant der kreml hier einen
angriff oder handelt es sich doch nur um
ein normales trainings manöver wie putin
behauptet unsere neue
verteidigungsministerin deutet es als
aggression es sagte sie in bild
christine lambrecht deutet das genauso
selbstbewusst richtung moskau sagt sie
wir müssen putin ins visier nehmen so
die spd politikern zudem müsste die für
die aggression verantwortlichen
persönliche konsequenzen spüren was das
konkret heißen soll das ist aber unklar
aber dass ihre erste dienstreise ins
direkt benachbarte litauen führt das ist
sicher kein zufall
als kalter wind und schneeregen in rogla
litauen die umstände der ersten
dienstreise der neuen
verteidigungsministerin christine
lambrecht sind frostig die neue
bedrohungslage durch russland ist auch
bei den deutschen nato-soldaten
allgegenwärtig besonders brisant ist die
situation an der russisch-ukrainischen
grenze hier sollen rund 100 tausend
russische soldaten stationiert sein ihre
mission noch unbekannt der kreml spricht
von einem harmlosen manöver zu
übungszwecken aber die nachbarstaaten
trauen dem russischen präsidenten nicht
zu frisch sind die erinnerungen der
russischen aktion der ukrainischen
halbinsel krim im jahr 2014 in sozialen
netzwerken aber auch auf
satellitenbildern erkennbar konvois mit
panzern massive truppen konzentration an
der grenze zur ukraine plant der kreml
hier einen angriff auf sein nachbarland
oder ist das alles nur säbelrasseln
nur wenige kilometer weiter auf der
ukrainischen seite ist die angst vor
einem einmarsch groß russland in die
grenzen weisen das versuchen europa die
nato und auch deutschland mit
angedrohten sanktion
bundesverteidigungsministerium christine
lambrecht will nun putin ins visier
nehmen was das genau bedeutet wird sich
zeigen
gestern war sie noch mit der neuen
verteidigungsministerin in litauen und
jetzt schon wieder steht sie bei uns im
studio unsere politik kollegin lydia
rosenfelder ist bei uns halo die reise
von christine lambrecht nach litauen
warum dieser ort und was hast du
gemeinsam mit der ministerin bei dieser
reise erlebt also dass sie nach litauen
geflogen ist das war kein zufall denn
dort ist die enhanced vor ort präsenz
stationiert eine kampftruppe die
deswegen dort stationiert ist aufgrund
einer schon früher früheren aggressionen
russlands als russland nachdem russland
die ukrainische grimme annektierte wurde
dort als reaktion 2017 eben wurden diese
kampftruppen dort stationiert
deutschland führt die derzeit an und das
ist so dass die ostflanke sichern sollen
also quasi der auch eben als
gegenreaktion auf die russische
aggression ist ein anrecht war vorher
justizministerin dann auch in
personalunion noch familienministerin
jetzt ist die verteidigungsministerin
wie hat sie sich geschlagen wie hast du
sie wahrgenommen ganz wacker würde ich
sagen das ist ja schon eine umstellung
stadt große gesetze jetzt großes gerät
schützenpanzer schnellfeuerwaffen man
merkt dass sie noch damit fremdelt aber
dass sie das trotzdem sehr interessiert
aufnimmt aufsaugt sie will sich jetzt
auch dann nachdem sie jetzt so viele
truppenbesuche gemacht hat und ihre
erste einsatz reise jetzt ein paar tage
zeit nehmen und eigene schlüsse daraus
zu ziehen sich eigene gedanken zu machen
wie das beschaffungswesen verbessert
werden kann wie man mit
auslandseinsätzen umgeht aber man merkt
schon dass ist als alle ein komplett
neues thema für sie als militärischen
partner zu der situation vor ort gesagt
man merkte über den tag hinweg dass ihre
statements schärfer wurden das war schon
eine deutliche druckbetankung durch
unter anderem den litauischen
verteidigungsminister und auch natürlich
die truppen vor ort die ihre eindrücke
geschildert haben also die sind sehr
sehr besorgt das hat dann dazu geführt
dass christine lambrecht am ende des
tages den satz sagte der an den früheren
verteidigungsminister peter struck
argumente der hat er mal gesagt die
sicherheit deutschlands wird auch am
hindukusch verteidigt
und christine lambrecht sagte die
sicherheit litauens ist auch unsere
sicherheit